cinq personnes possèdent autant que 27
millions d'autres dans ce pays
un déséquilibre pareil est insupportable
moralement et intellectuellement nous
avons besoin de répartir pour pouvoir
faire
la vie à laquelle on aspire qu il n'est
pas si prétentieuse que ça je le dis à
monsieur macro nous nous élevons nos
enfants
en les protégeant du rêve dément et
pervers d'être milliardaire
puisqu'il avait dit que je devais en
rêvait
alors si cette petite phrase qui a fait
énormément parler je voudrais voir
d'abord ceux qui ont été choqués par
cette phrase on paye des jeux gais
valeritas été choqués ou choquer
n'exagérons pas mais c'est dans la
logique mélenchonistes c'est à dire
qu'effectivement si on suit ce que
disent ce que dit la france à insoumise
l'argent capitaliste ce n'est pas la
vertu cardinale il ya le partage il ya
des valeurs qui structure la pensée de
la france aso vise néanmoins moi ce qui
me ce qui me gêne c'est ce manichéisme
fin chez jean luc mélenchon parce qu'il
il oppose des milliardaires qui seraient
éventuellement qui serait
intrinsèquement des méchants les
milliardaires selon la chaîne
il ya plein de mots je comprends mal
j'ai décroché moi même accès que là j'ai
dit là là là je les entends tu vois les
marseillais
jean luc mélenchon nous dit et il n'y
croit pas lui-même c'est-à-dire la
région les l'argent les milliardaires
c'est des méchants les pauvres cd gentil
tu vas passer le week end et il sait
très bien que l'on peut pas résumer la
vie avec cette grille de lecture là d'un
côté les bons de l'autre les méchants il
ya aussi le milliardaire qui ce qui ne
sont pas rêver milliardaire ils se sont
réveillés à bord avec des idées avec une
envie de changer le monde avec des
envies de chefs d'entreprise
éventuellement ils sont devenus
milliardaires comme comme b sosuco bill
gates voilà après après j'ai créé des
emplois et créer et surtout voilà je
voulais dire aussi c'est qu'un
milliardaire il est pas que milliardaire
pour lui il génère de l'emploi assure
donc qui voient là le avoir un deux
trois autres mois progrès à qu'elle va
répondre benjamin cap et c'est vrai que
c'est manichéen dire que cinq personnes
possèdent ce que n'ont pas 27 millions
moi je préférais qui disent il ya cinq
personnes qui font manger peut-être 10
15 20 millions de personnes et c'est la
vérité un pays on a en france on pas
qu'elle en france on a un vrai problème
c'est que les gens qui réussissent on
les aime pas c'est le procès permanent
des gens qui ont trop d'argent parce
qu'ils ont certaines ont pris de
l'argent je sais pas qui en france
quelqu'un qui a réussi qui sait
quelqu'un de suspect c'est pas bien il
faut encourager des enfants a réussi
alors peut-être pas les millionnaires
milliardaires mais pourquoi tu veux les
rennais restent interdits balle le
minaret est le méchant un rêve démont
s'est pas démonté de vouloir tenir des
anciens arrête tout court non
honnêtement tu aurais fait j'aurais pas
d'être j'ai pas une princesse quand tu
étais petit et c'en est une ac oui même
du queens à mais voilà on a tous très
contemporain c'est sain soumise par
humain va je coupe le voile alors tout
ça pas bien alors
protéger nos enfants du rêve dément et
pervers d'être milliardaire dans
milliardaire ça passe pas millionnaire
ça passe juste pas savoir c'est quoi la
lecture et de mélenchon non moi j'essaie
d'apprendre à mes enfants d'avoir des
rêves d'être heureux et d'avoir de
l'ambition de croire en la marquant la
méritocratie et moi si ma fille elle me
dit j'ai envie d'être millionnaire parce
que je vais prendre lui apprendre à dire
ou à deux as rêvé éventuellement pauvres
ou précaires ont pas savoir ce qu'elle
va manger les 18 mois je trouve que
c'est pas un plan de carrière un plan de
vie un plan même d'utopie et en fait je
trouve que c'est voilà c'est une sorte
de nivellement vers le bas à chaque fois
dans lequel mélenchon veut nous aspirer
et qui ne me plaît pas parce que c'est
démagogique et on fait croire aux gens
que si on tape les riches on va rendre
les pauvres plus riches et ça marche pas
comme ça selon moi et encore une fois
oui il ya plein milliards r comme par
exemple le bill gates ou comme j'ai pas
warren buffet tous à qui on donnait
beaucoup à plein de saveurs sa gloire et
des fans milliardaire bon voilà et
parlant je pense à bape est par exemple
bape et c'est un multi multi multi multi
millionnaire et vous avez killing ont
bondi vous devez le savoir ils inondent
bondi de l'argent qu'il a gagné donc
voilà c'est encore une fois stigmatisant
ses manichéen et je pense qu'on rend pas
service à la société française a
stigmatisé les riches alors vraiment non
alors il faut il faut des gens tout en
haut pour que les autres les autres
puissent vivre moi je suis ouvrier je te
prête ouvriers moi ce que je veux dire
mon fils c'est d'essayer de se battre
justement pour ne pas être ouvrier pour
essayer d'être un peu plus haut dans la
classe sociale n'y a pas de honte à ne
pas vouloir de milliardaires peut-être
pas mais y'a pas de honte vraiment et
comme l'a dit benjamin il faut des gens
puissants pour qu'on puisse nous aussi
manger au tour là où la raison mélenchon
sait que les richesses sont mal répartis
partout mais j'aurais envie de lui dire
à lui aussi à monsieur mélenchon sait
que depuis 83 depuis 76 il est dans la
politique depuis 83 îles et s'il est élu
il a gagné tout son argent sur le dos
des français qui travaillaient pas lui
lui il a créé aucune richesse il ay là
il a gagné son argent par l'impôt des
français et aujourd'hui ils pètent pas
obligés de cumuler les mandats comme il
l'a fait dans les années d'avant pour
toucher des sommes dix douze mille euros
par mois il peut aussi travailler pour
2500 euros si ça lui plaît pas d'être
milliardaire c'est ça son discours qui
est bizarre avec jean luc mélenchon jean
luc mélenchon sait qui dit c'est pas
beau l'argent c'est pas beau et riche
c'est pas beau d'être milliardaire mais
depuis 76 83 il vit que de l'argent des
impôts en fait il vit pas de son travail
à lui je préfère un patrick maquel qui
vit de son travail et qui donne du
travail aux autres plutôt que quelqu'un
qui donne des leçons sans lui jamais
n'avoir travaillé là jamais travaillé
j'ai ris répondre vite fait à ça parce
que jean luc mélenchon et skype à dix ou
douze mille euros par mois il a jamais
gagné même canon avec un cumul des
mandats renom c'était d'ailleurs une
feuille qui nous qui avait le que
l'extrême droite avait diffusé il y
avait eu beaucoup de mails parce qu'il
prétendait qu'on pouvait être à la fois
député européen et sénateurs ou je sais
pas quoi mais c'était faux c'est pas
vrai on fait la moyenne des français
cette ville sicilienne pas 1006 par mois
mais se mêleront n'y a aucun il ya aucun
parlementaire qui éclaircissent d'accord
mais sauf que raymond raymond et alors
tu préfère quand même d'avoir des
députés qui demandent le smic à 1400
euros qui veulent bloquer les prix
qu'ils veulent la retraite à 60 ans ou
tu veux des députés en plus vont à
l'assemblée nationale pour dire qu' il
faut qu'on gagne peu qu'il faut qu'on
travaille jusqu'à la mort moi j'en des
députés sont les français et ben réputé
qu'il fait le sureau grave dans leur
pays je veux des députés 1,3000 barça
c'est je pense y a pas besoin de
convaincre c'est très bien très près et
très bien on peut on peut absolument
rediscuter des vols vendu des abbassides
ya pas de soucis mais l'a pour l'instant
j'ai été invité à rediscuter d'herlies
les milliardaires ont peut-être commencé
par un nom millionaire est ce que je
connais un peu la manoeuvre qui consiste
à dire les milliardaires n'en parlons
pas en revanche on va parler des élus et
notamment des élus un sourire qui
peut-être n'ont d'existence personnel
qui pourrait peut-être faire libérer des
salaires plus élevés encore dans le
privé je pense par exemple à manuel
bompard qui était le directeur de la
campagne ce mec il est docteur voulez
sur mathématiques les et parfums sort le
débat je trouve que ce soit oui
inclusive add des élus de la france sont
tous les élus vous nous vendez des 90 s
est pas la même chose d'avoir un été
noir c'est des voix raymond au fond que
ces mots vous payez pas la dévoreuse
vous avez des frais de campagne vous
avez des frais mort et ne dit pas vous
ben pas venue des petits pas vous moi
j'ai pas député non mais c'est à vous je
dis juste que c'est pas la même chose
pour les pour les français pour les gens
à la maison c'est pas la même chose que
tu as 2 189 députés de la nouvelle union
populaire qui vont vraiment augmenter
les salaires pour tous les français qui
travaillent qui vont vraiment s'assurer
qu'effectivement 92 des français pour
cent des français payent moins d'impôts
pour que les 8% qu'il ya eu du travail
paie un peu plus pour qu'on ait des
écoles pour qu'on ait la santé pour que
la pâte se sent vraiment en discours sur
les gens tu veux pas parler des gens tu
parles de ta situation personnelle et tu
as raison mais il ya quinze jours en
france et à deux gamins adolescents qui
sont morts de faim mais oui on essaye il
n'y a pas que deux ya pas l hiver dans
l'arve
grave
c'est bien sûr c'est à cause des
milliards gerland des patois et entraîne
tout que les autres n'ont rien dans la
mine at il des gens crèvent de
qu'est-ce que tu sais pas tu verras
d'ipads en
28 milliards da
rapporte efe des sacs new york c'est
avec
le nom de fille de pas équipé le
rayonnement à travers le monde entier au
loin je dansais gérard dine je pense que
ces voiles rien donné nous les français
on produit chaque année par notre
travail par le fait qu'on consomme par
le fait qu'on utilise les services
publics ont créé deux mille milliards
d'euros par année c'est nous qui
fabriquons cet argent là y'a aucun ultra
riches qui est riche dans un océan de
vide même cyril si tu veux prendre la
richesse de série dont je ne connais pas
l'ordre de grandeur l'ampleur et bien et
bien cette richesse de civils elle est
directement liée au fait que
actuellement à la maison il ya un an 1
million unique personnes qui regardent
l'émission il n'est pas riche tout seul
eh ben ils arrivent
à participer à cette richesse on aurait
donc vous aider avec ton discours
géraldine qui consiste à penser que les
ultra riches sont riches parce qu'ils
sont meilleurs que nous non c'est pareil
nous alimente c'est nous qui alimentons
les ultra-riches personnes ne payant
plus personne peut faire ce que fernando
ben oui pardon est ce que
tu es d'accord aussi liquide en sondant
son géraldine ci est plus de public et
bains publics et bal à voula tous bords
découpés toi bien on égare journal
rappelle celle là c'est pas ces
accusations séparé de manger il ya plus
leclerc il ya plus carrefour ya puis au
chant on a cassé
l'irak est réfléchie n'ont jamais là je
dis des trucs le point qui j'achète chez
vous alors leur argent grâce au public
je pense que le public sait que j'ai
raison même si tu n'as pas si tu portes
de phoebe donc et on vivait je voulais
dire c'est que pour revenir à nos
enfants qu'on éduque tous oui j'ai trois
enfants sont nés en embrouille c'est
avoir des enfants quand ils sont petits
on leur dit pas soyez milliardaire je
suis absolument convaincu alors aucun
autour de la table qui a dit ça doit
métier bâti vous dis je m y avait un
maghrébin conviendront chat non moi j'ai
parlé à mes enfants j'ai d'abord je leur
parle des parcours de leurs
grands-parents et cetera demi qui
étaient pauvres et les petits qui bat
wii qui ont travaillé toute l'année bien
votre vie mines on a donc fait ils ont
posé un sort aux enfants bien sûr et ben
moi j'ai repris mes études à 35 ans et
je suis devenue avocate je me suis battu
et c'est ça que j'essaie de transmettre
à la jeune vierge aurait toujours
d'ailleurs laisse à nos enfants des fois
ils nous regardent y va où il veut faire
comme nous moi j'ai beaucoup été élevé
chez moi dans ma famille parce que
c'était mon histoire dans la peur de la
pauvreté moi je sais que mes parents
m'ont éduqué dans la peur de la pauvreté
mes enfants n'ont pas peur de la
pauvreté et mais en revanche personne de
que je connais personne n'a vécu dans le
rêve d'être milliardaire personne parce
qu'en plus à l'époque où nous vivons où
l'écosystème de la planète ne peut pas
supporter les milliardaires vous savez
que il ya 10% des plus riches qui
provoque 50% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre si vos enfants pour
éduquer qu'ils soient en permanence avec
ses jets à bruxelles
si tes enfants deviennent milliardaire
tu vas être triste pour eux mêmes et les
cheveux et j'espère bien que je serai au
gouvernement et que je vais les imposer
ils vont payer des impôts c'est quand
même
mais c'est très bien ce que dira qu'elle
n'a plus que ce que tu dis là c'est ce
que françois hollande avait essayé de
faire il avait dit au dessus d'un
million je vais imposer à 80% je les ai
répondu cela
n'était pas pressé non non non non c'est
pas ça
pour
l'évasion fiscale une évasion semenov
énormément mais raymond yapi l'évasion
fiscale et la reine laquelle puisque ça
a été retoquée au conseil
constitutionnel c'est une mesure
confiscatoire et rêveur la vérité c'est
qu'il ya tout un tas de richesses qui ne
fonctionne que sur les consommateurs
français peut par exemple ans pour
revenir à notre ami série le celi peut
pas se démoraliser suffit
d'insérer des métis il
est heureux principe donc donc soyons
soyons confiants que nous en tant que
peuple et 65 millions on crée des
richesses on consomme on étudie et
aujourd'hui on a un système économique
qui fait ben je sais pas par exemple à
l'hôpital avicenne à bobigny manque pour
fermer quoi il abat des années et bien
voilà formidable l'égérie soignants ont
gâché leur vie leur énergie leur sens
très à l'aise mais succion gamberge être
allé aux arts geraldton on a une petite
discussion ekra quelques rappels quand
on s'appelait qu'est ce qu'on a et on
était un petit peu sur la même longueur
d'onde mais on s'est dit un truc tout
les nous on en avait juste envie on se
rejoignait sur un truc je dis moi
j'aimerais voilà j'aimerais que les gens
que je côtoie des gens que je reçois sur
mon plateau les gens qui me regardent
puisse voilà qui fait la vie avec un
salaire plus que décent et qui soit
voilà et c'est ce qu'on s'est dit j'ai
dit voilà après il faut trouver la bonne
formule le bon curseur mais c'est vrai
que c'est ce qu'on s'est dit on sait ni
voilà il ya le curseur jean-luc je pense
voilà qui à tour soeur entre les deux
mais c'est vrai que je suis d'accord
avec toi et ça tu le sais jamais
beaucoup que et moi je quand je vois un
je te dis quand je vois des ddd des
français je te lis qu'ils sont qui
arrive pas à aller au restaurant une
fois pas mois qui arrivent pas aller au
cinéma a une qui arrive pas à faire des
qui qui qui survivent qui ne vivent qu'à
kia qui survivent moi je me dis il ya un
truc qui merde il faut faire quelque
chose mais bien assez sûre et et c'est
vrai que voilà je peux comprendre à ceux
d'irak et parlait d'ailleurs enfin tous
les deux je dis voilà et il faudrait
trouver le curseur voilà pour que j'ai
moi comme j'ai dit moi je moi mon rêve
serait que tous les français soient
riches est rien
pas fou et l'iran ferrari non mais voilà
la planète ne pas supporter
mais déjà si on peut manger des aliments
de qualité mais c'est ça redémarre scié
et pas juste des gagne pas et faisait
rentrer payer l'électricité est
achetable et chaussures c'est ça le truc
c'est à voir aussi des loisirs il ya de
plus en plus urgent en france et qui
survit exactly ne manque plus qu on va
en parler dans un master zen dire ce que
vous en pensez géraldine et puis on va
reparler de cette jeune femme agressée
humiliés par des candidats de télé
réalité sur les réseaux sociaux doha le
principal intéressé sur le bateau et
l'avocate de cette jeune fille et raquel
reste avec nous et diatonique ivo de
parler tenir le corse je veux dire
bonjour il ya des jeunes à bobigny tout
à l'heure devant le jld étaient devant
l'école langevin et on part les
hologrammes et oui et il ya un gène ont
parlé du programme et je disais que si
c'était mélenchon le premier ministre ma
retraite serait à 60 ans et que nos
parents fatigués pourrait ne pas mourir
au travail et se reposer un peu et il
est lui était très jeune il m'a dit mais
ça c'est bien madame alors qu'en fait
nos enfants c'est pas leur problème
d'être milliardaire il faudrait déjà une
que leurs parents et leurs grands cris
n'a pas vivre dignement vous êtes
d'accord oui je suis d'accord je pense
pas que jean luc mélenchon déteste les
gens qui gagnent de l'argent je pense
qu'il est là pour dénoncer les
inégalités syrie permettez moi de vous
sucer 30 secondes
mais je concède faut distinguer pas plus
je pense qu'il faut distinguer les gens
comme cyril qui effectivement gagnent
très bien leur vie et c'est mérité mais
qui pourront être un entrepreneur social
et qui traitent bien les gens qui payent
bien ses collaborateurs qui toujours
dans le respect et certains
millionnaires ou milliardaires qui
gagnent de l'argent de manière moins
honnêtes et sa chance que c'est une
réalité ensuite moi le deuxième message
que je vois dans la phrase de jean luc
mélenchon c'est qu'être riche un message
qui est envoyé aux jeunes être riche
c'est pas une fin en soi et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux
avec instagram ya plein de jeunes qui se
disent voilà moi pour être accompli
heureux et avoir réussi ma vie dans tous
les sens du terme ça passe par une
réussite financière obligatoirement
ville et je pense que c'est très moyen
en mangent ensemble après taquine et
adrien qui me demande si ça marche
depuis ce soit
et donc je pense que c'est voilà c'est
il faut dire aux jeunes que ce n'est pas
une fin en soi d'être riche parce que
certains jeunes aujourd'hui sont prêts à
tout pour devenir riche quitte à faire
n'importe quoi on l'a vu et donc je
pense que ce qu'il dit est très
intelligent et c'est pas une haine des
riches ou des gens qui viennent de
l'argent c'est juste mieux répartir les
richesses
pour dire c'est notre dernier repas pour
le régime
c'est vrai que c'est beau ce que tu
aimerais vraiment mais je te dis c'est
un entrepreneur c'est un plaisir de se
faire sucer pas
[Rires]
génial et un appel à la générosité au
partage c'est ça qui me plaît c'est pour
ça que je dis oui je suis chaud avec lui
la france crève des inégalités c'est pas
possible de continuer comme ça c'est
bien que les gens gagnent de l'argent
mais si on redistribue pas on est foutu
donc j'ai pris ça non pas pour un
look has pour un ultimatum c'est pas
amour les riches et essayer de partager
s'ils n'ont plus rien n'est possible
dans la société française donc je suis
pas d'accord avec tout ce qu'il dit mais
là je suis à 100% avec lui désaccord
avec cette action n'est pas d'accord
avec ce qu'il dit c'est qu'ils veulent
les ambassades turques un peu ici tu as
chaud là où tu souhaites tu fais ton
constat grave du maintien lui il a des
les trucs importants ils comptent le
plus pour moi c'est chez cet homme
pudique où cité dans ce parti c'est dans
cette non mais c'est vrai qu'il soit là
c'est après que ça avec d'accord avec
toi c'est quelqu'un qui avait quelque
chose à dire d'intéressant avant la pub
c'est toi tony écoute moi je pense que
les milliardaires il y en a toujours eu
et aura toujours qui la gauche les
communistes qui que ce soit y aura
toujours des milliards dia pourquoi
attaquer les milliardaires
redistribuer quoi les milliardaires qui
ont redistribué qu'est ce que vous
voulez qu'ils redistribuent les
milliardaires des bases et
je leur demandais comment parler c'est
bien ça waouh crois que j'ai bien sûr
vous savez c'est je répète pas le
chiffre qu'a donné jean luc mélenchon
mais cinq personnes qui gagnent autant
que 27 millions verardo parler indécent
d'impôt sur les sociétés par an mais pas
de bazas et 1,9 au test bazas et il ya
un autre élément aussi qu'il faut il
faut qu'on congolais grèce 5 et 10% des
personnes les plus riches sur terre
fabrique autant de gaz à effet de serre
que la moitié de la planète
en fait c'est à dire on parle des
questions environnementales on dit il
faut changer nos modes de consommation
mais en fait c'est 10% des ultra riches
qui sont en train de nous condamner
comme espèce à mourir donc même même si
vous avez des amis milliardaires ils
peuvent comprendre qu'ils peuvent pas
mettre en cause la survie de notre
espèce quand même à me regarder on va
parler guerre mondiale
avant tonique oui je veux savoir à la
france a soumis au nouveau
nouvelle
écologique et sociale n'eurent pas de
riches mais il y en a peut-être est
alors payer des impôts ils sont sur le
barème il ya un barème d'imposition à
tête ans tranché le répète 92 % des
contribuables français paieront moins
d'impôts si jean luc mélenchon est
premier ministre voilà et puis surtout
tu regardes pourtant fait partie des 6 %
ça c'est avec plaisir c'est bien mais
c'est bien de dire ça c'est bien parce
que le côté par exemple souvent on nous
dit oui il y aura deux il y aura de
l'exil fiscal mais alors ces gens sont
pas patriotes s'ils partent juste leur
soutien une panacée qui est son nom on
est patriote sûr qu'ils sont pas là mais
pas tous vous avez y ait des tableaux si
vous attaquez moi j'ai parfois j'entends
les hommes politiques qui veulent
attaquer les impôts un français sur deux
ne payent pas d'impôts en france le
revenu
ne payent pas d'impôts la tva c'est pour
tout le monde moi je dis jusqu au lieu
de vous concentrer sur les impôts
concentrez-vous sur le prix des loyers
qui flambent kibboutzique la vidéo si
concentrez-vous sur l'électricité qui
vous y la vie des gens concentrez-vous
sur les orages des prix bluesy la vie
blocage des cous sûrs de vous concentrer
sur un impôt ou certains payent 800 900
euros d'impôts ce qui est déjà beaucoup
vous concentrer là dessus et vous
concentrer pas sur les vrais problèmes
fait amazon ne paye pas d'impôts ça
dérange personne tu as des grandes
chaînes de fast-food qui ne payent pas
d'impôts ça dérange personne est ce que
vous allez range ne payent pas d'impôts
vous prenez des hubert tu sais tu
pourquoi vous montez dans d hubert ne
monte pas dans d hubert hummer ne payent
pas d'impôts en france et pourtant ça
vous dérange pas de monter dans un
hummer meriem au macumba
[Applaudissements]
les commandes à la commande et sur un an
mais il paye maintenant ils ont bien un
impôt mais oui
raymond premièrement bon je recommande
pas sur amazon c'est d'amuser l'astuce
qui construit qu'on qui consiste à
culpabiliser le consommateur plutôt que
s'en prendre à des ventes joseph véloce
pardon raquette je comptabilise qu'aucun
consommateur est le gros chamakh at il
déjà élèves et le consommateur
le procès accuse pas mais sont tombés
dimanche
8 euros sur amazon et qu'il a le même
produit à trente deux uvres sur ailleurs
il projette la vie de pascal et en
galets xvi en 24 heures ils attendent
une soirée nous c'est ça qu'il faut
remettre ces corps fort était de
mélenchon de dire les impôts les impôts
les impôts qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
les riches quand vous allez imposé qui
vont barrer et vous répond vous pouvez
pas dire aussi à favoriser la vérité et
la vérité sont les regards deux états
unis comme
les écoutes raymond écoute moi on fera
ça
on fera ça ici auquel on habite là on
fera ça ici ça s'appelle le fatca
foreign account tax compliance act mm
toi tu vas juste leur faire ça parce que
là je m'appelle fatca foreign account
tax compliance act tous les américains
où qu'ils soient dans le monde ils
doivent déclarer
une fois les mots on fera pareil on l'a
dit on l'a dit sur tous les tons le le
programme économique budgétaire de
mélenchon il en béton armé ne t'inquiète
pas en revanche en dix ans à partir des
besoins on a besoin entre préserver la
planète on a besoin de vivre dignement
on a besoin d'être heureux on a besoin
de mon gamin étudie pour a justement
visé cette ambition cet avancement
reprise économique ont bien pourcentage
milles de son mondial nous la france on
représente combien d heures sans talent
combien on va présente parce que
j'entends surtout c'est la planète mais
je veux aussi que les français ou les
monnaies les milliards
pour cent la france est responsable
combien de l'apologie d'un rien l'an et
les autres arts et chenaux et la france
représentée à % de l'avem son mondial
collège monnet paquet il est celui qui
voyage et carillon est celui qui a du
mal à manger qui lui ne produit phare
dont j'ai vu ce film
ah
oui quand même l'économiste
avec des pincettes je vais quitter la
france si rien d'une course à dos de ses
résultats au niveau la pollution 1% et
c'est la chine serait bien si les
américains lundi je ne capte à sauver la
face
et parler de la cordillère des andes ça
c'est comme le nuage de tchernobyl qui
s'est arrêté à la frontière belge la
slovénie s'est arrêtée aventure belle tu
raquette répondants étaient fascinés en
inde qui a le plus de milliardaires il
ya les gens les plus riches oui du
pauvre aujourd'hui eh ben il ya des
pommes bien aussi des milliardaires en
chine et en inde dont les milliards il
ya un modèle économique par donc content
on fait le grand déménagement du monde
on va chercher fabriquer des produits en
chine pour les ramener ici c'est nous
qui les consomme aussi donc ça c'est les
riches en france qui ramène des produits
de là-bas n'est de toute façon les
études elle de salonique doit gérer les
secours qu'est-ce que vous deviez
attention à moi je me
rappelle ce sont les pauvres et les plus
précaires qui consomme chinois oui et
les bourses et les formations non non
non non c'est les études sont très
clairs là dessus je vous renvoie aux
études par exemple de greenpeace et
oxfam on est pauvre chambres sont très
faiblement émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre ça c'est vraiment c'est une donnée
très solide delà de la science et des
études faut pas culpabiliser les gens en
leur faisant croire que parce que ils
achètent des des choses low cost c'est
eux qui sont en train d'abîmer la
planète l'équipe à ce sont les ultra
riches que vous défendrez bateau en
train d'abîmer la planète a de quoi
manger le 3 du moins vous pensez qu'ils
pensent vraiment la planète les plus
précaires ben non et alors donc d'abord
à mais vous vous pourriez peut-être y
penser mais moi je sais ce qu'est ce que
vous savez j'en suis ultra bas alors
puisqu'elle en est moi j'ai pas dit que
vous étiez le travail que j'ai dit que
quand je dis moi que les ultra riches
représentent 50 % des gaz émissions à
effet de serre au lieu de dire ben
résolvant ce problème vous parler
d'autre chose et vous dites que je texte
rôles et des milliardaires et est-ce
qu'on peut au moins se mettre d'accord
est ce qu'on a un problème survenu
la pollution sans les milliardaires mais
c'est un fait mais non mais arrêtez vous
remettez en cause sa les dernières
études
enfin soit vous allez bientôt dans
marrakech du hockey barak et lucia le
sondage qui varient mercy était là bas
ils voulaient pas vu ma wii à 36% non
c'est intéressant parce que nos
téléspectateurs sont pros mélenchon et
là ils sont contre mélenchon la plupart
du temps notre respect de nos
téléspectateurs qui sont avec moi ils
sont plus ou moins fous non ils sont non
non ça
veut dire quoi ça sert à quoi non mais à
la vrai dire dit est ce que vous vous
êtes choqué il a dû
veut bien laisser déraper sur les
régions il n'y a pas de problème on veut
bien leur prendre tout leur pognon n'y a
pas de problème ajoute quand tout allait
bien on leur prend tout leur argent père
et quand ils vont se marrer je vais
quand même
de quoi le fait qu'à allah alors si vous
voulez faire comme des pays étrangers
alors les états unis après tu te payes
communique enfin les députés à
l'assemblée si vous l'allaitez colonel
députés à l'assemblée tu leur diras tu
es amis politiques arrêtés bien entendu
toujours des exemples d autres pays
parce que la france le champion des
taxes mais oui on a mal l'allemagne pays
- taxe sur la société que nous sommes
est bien celui tarifs et de taxes sur le
tabac ont baissé les bras arrêtez de me
prendre des exemples
92 % des contribuables et minéraux moins
d'impôts si jean luc mélenchon est
premier ministre on y mange bien payer
des impôts parce que si on paye des
impôts et cela veut dire qu'on est
content ça marche parce qu'il ya des
gens la nuit pas assez d'impôts et un
tas de gens qui paient trop et moi je
suis comblé les aurais les groupes
emmaüs les gens ne veulent pas aller
vous payez des impôts les gens veut
qu'on baisse les charges et les gens et
vous voulez vous regardez les rockets
être éduqués on est là qu il faut partir
des besoins loyer